let's listen to a guy who may be this
year's face to the NFL the guy we're
expecting a huge leap from in 2020
former center fielder of the Oklahoma
Sooners Kyler Murray here's what he said
yesterday you all be doing like I said I
stand for what's right
and at the bottom line you know I call
it like I see it and what's been going
on is completely wrong so I'll be doing
and Kyler Murray let me tell you
something there's a fire burning inside
of him somebody called him out on
Instagram somebody attacked him on
Instagram he went F bomb Chris in
response so Connor Murray's not messing
around people aren't messing around
people are taking this situation very
very seriously the world has changed in
the last 24 days and you either
acknowledge it or you end up seeming
completely and totally out of touch
ideally you change with it ideally we
all have adjusted the way we view these
issues and for the most part what I've
look what I've seen is there are plenty
of people who are and there are plenty
of very loud people who aren't but
that's not stopping what the NFL and
others are doing Chris so you know this
is this is just gonna continue and I I
respect the fact that the NFL is just
ignoring the noise but the reality is
there's gonna be plenty of noise yeah
there's gonna be noise there's no doubt
about it I mean we know the president's
very passionate about the issue but so
is the NFL I think so is the American
Society for the most part I do you know
it's not going anywhere
and I think the NFL is gonna continue to
support the players and go from there to
and hey listen I think people's eyes
have been opened up to with this a
little bit you know I hear some people
say oh you can't sweat no I I think
there's some people out there who have
looked at what has happened here
recently like we've said who you know
maybe we're supporting the good fight
but now they're in the fight or even
people who might have been more on the
Trump side of things I think there's
even a few here with even this subject
not saying they don't support Trump
anymore but they look at this subject
and go oh no there's there's something
wrong here something needs to be done
and you know as far as Kyle
I give them a lot of credit again you
know he's a very mature he's wise beyond
his years for sure as far as what does
their thank you I did it beyond and you
know I think guys like Kyle Emery are
just they're sick of like you know that
guy on Twitter who's like I got a black
friend I'm not racist but yet there's
like you know ten other things he does
in life that kind of insinuate he might
be a racist and I think you know me and
after you know african-american players
and everything like that are just
they're sick of those people so if we
don't need you whatever f off and
whatever it will do you know and see you
later here's the bigger point to him we
need to take a break but I I you know I
have a hard time reconciling the
freedoms that we supposedly enjoy as
Americans with this idea that it is
mandatory you must stand for the anthem
you must put your hand over your heart
you must salute you must wait a minute I
thought we were in a country that wasn't
about must I thought we were in a
country that was about you have the
power to choose what you want to do
that's part of the freedom that we enjoy
up to and including the free I remember
when I was in law school one of the big
issues for the US Supreme Court was
whether or not you have the right to
burn the American flag and I remember
initially being just perplexed what well
wait a minute wait a minute burn the
American flag who would want to do that
and then when you think about it it's
like well if we truly have freedom in
this country you have the freedom to
feel that way the rest of us have the
freedom to disagree but you do have the
freedom to express yourself that way if
you choose to do so and this is a much
much more you know
constrained version of that mindset but
but the point is I you know hey the
thing that made us American should make
us resist this idea of thou shalt do
this and thou shalt do that that that's
how the country got started there were
too many value shots coming coming from
the king in England all right we got it
well the thing that drives me crazy Mike
is thou shalt not do this for some
things but then other things where they
don't you know people don't want to bend
no that one's okay thou shalt take that
hat off during the national
some people leave that on all the time
no I you know I just get sick of that
talk and it's okay to get a hot dog it's
okay to go to the bathroom
it's okay years around it's okay it's
okay to be on your phone it's okay to do
all sorts of things haphazardly and
accidentally but you and it's a pizza
Pete's trying to stir up trouble in my
ear here but it's but it's not okay to
conscientiously conscientiously and
deliberately for the purposes of sending
an important societal message that
people have yet to to recognize it's not
okay
to do that it's okay to just kind of
bumble around and disrespect the anthem
it's not okay to deliberately send a
message that you say is not about
disrespecting the anthem it's about
making sure people understand there's a
bigger point out there there's a bigger
problem that needs to be
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports